[Music]
some people might not like museums but
sometimes you're forced to visit them
and make the most of the situation
luckily there are some snapchat people
out there who can really make us laugh
out loud wait until you see the most
relatable dinosaur snapchat ever if
you're new here subscribe to our Channel
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up now get ready to giggle as
we look at 20 snapchat captions that
make art fun again contour let's start
with some of our absolute favorite
captions ever if you love to contour
your face and enhance your facial
features you know that this caption is
absolutely relatable and describes
perfectly what we might feel like before
we contour this might just be an art
piece but it sometimes definitely
applies to real-life situations
do you even have a face before you
contour according to this snapchat you
don't and it's absolutely hilarious
because it's true all we'd like to see
now is an after contour example of an
artistic painting we love contemporary
arts but that's not the only snapchat
caption that made us giggle correcting
grammar everyone's grammar was corrected
on the Internet at some point including
ours
nobody's perfect but sometimes people
just don't hold back it looks like that
even Jesus wants to roll his eyes so
next time someone on the internet
decides to take your grammar too
seriously
just send them the snapchat his hands
and the look on his face really do look
like he's had enough of just about
everything they really want to know what
made him look so annoyed because the
look on his face is definitely not a
happy one maybe it really was the fact
he got corrected on his grammar board
the longer you look at people in
portraits the more things you'll start
to notice in the background but
sometimes their look sets at all and a
lot of times they are completely bored
we're not sure if this is really what
was happening in this picture but the
looks of both ladies make it seem like
they're really having the worst time of
their lives the caption says literally
this is so boring and it's definitely
relatable especially if you've been
forced to visit an art museum and didn't
enjoy it at all it looks like some of
these paintings share your feelings
do you enjoy art let us know in the
comments can't touch me
all of these art paintings really make
us wonder if that's actually what people
looked like at the time check out this
guy he has a lot of muscles doesn't he
but the way his body is twisted and the
position of his arm really made it seem
like he's walking down the catwalk
saying nobody can touch him because he's
fabulous we bet his walk is pretty sassy
too and it seems like the woman that
to him knows this as well let us know if
you're familiar with any of these art
pieces and what you think these people
are thinking Mean Girls reference if
you're not a fan of the movie you might
not get this but we promise that it's
still hilarious Mean Girls references in
our history are our favorites but this
one probably wins them all raise your
hand if you know who said this quote and
what happened to the movie at the time
it looks like it definitely fits this
statue because it's true his hair does
look good when it's pushed back doesn't
he look handsome get in loser we're
going to an art museum and see how many
Mean Girls references we can come up
with we bet we'd be able to find quite a
few you can't sit with us and she
doesn't even go here moments real-life
crossover you won't believe this next
caption it's definitely one of our
favorites yet because the situation
makes it that much more perfect it seems
like this museum art made a crossover
with real life check it out doesn't it
look like these two are actually talking
about the woman sleeping on the chair
Jesus is definitely asking what is going
on here whether this was an accidental
shot or something that was setup it's
absolutely hilarious just look at how
the woman in the painting is looking at
the Sleeping Lady it seems like she's
holding a grudge doesn't she
Jesus doesn't seem impressed that the
lady's sleeping on the job does he
Tuesday
don't people in the paintings look
absolutely bored half of the time find
any historical painting and see what
they look like
we guarantee most of them have an
exhausted look on their face and it's
not just their face sometimes the whole
figure looks like it's having the worst
time ever and would love to see it all
end it definitely looks like this lady
just realized that it's only Tuesday and
she has a long way to go before she can
enjoy the weekend
we'd love to know what made her feel so
tired in real life and surely leaning on
her hands that way can't be that
comfortable Friday really can't arrive
faster can it selfie snapchat taught us
that some people are just incredibly
creative and can come up with some of
the funniest captions ever we really
wonder how bored the person who took
this caption was when they were in a
museum check it out it really looks like
the statue is actually taking a selfie
speaking of these people requested
multiple statues of themselves with
altered versions to show off their best
qualities we're pretty sure that's still
not as bad as people who are criticizing
the selfie generation if historians had
access to taking selfies we sure they
would have not hesitated to take them on
a daily basis and then turn it into a
ghost at
to the Bachelorette oh look it's the
portrait of The Bachelorette Season 1
cast you have to admit that watching the
lives of historians would be an amazing
reality show who's getting the 2 who has
more money who's starting another fight
for whatever reason doesn't it all
remind you of the Bachelorette we're
pretty sure you'd be able to find the
same historical cast and from the looks
of it this family would really fit in
the show think about all the drama we
could watch thumbs up to the person who
thought of this hilarious caption for
this family portrait resting man face
we've all heard of the RBF a term that
describes women's faces which seem just
a bit too serious at all times we can
imagine you can find a lot of those when
you walk through an art museum and look
at the portrait but this snapchat
caption took it to a new level
meet the RMF we have many more questions
about this photo why does he look so sad
why is he wearing a dress what happens
immediately after the photo he looks
totally over taking that portrait see
it's not only women who have the RBF we
bet over half of the male portraits have
it - hello ladies while most art
portraits come across as serious and
very mysterious there are a few that
seem to have more fun than others we've
already shown you some of the most
fabulous captions we have ever seen but
this sassy man wins them all he looks
way too smug for his own good
but you have to admit that it's
absolutely hilarious it really does look
like he's saying hello to all the ladies
out there and being super flirty the way
he's posing is completely hilarious that
is until you see what this man is
actually standing on it's got a dog's
head on the Left he's really not that
attractive reflection if there's one
thing we've learned today it's that
people on snapchat are incredibly
creative either that or they just get
easily bored in a museum
remember Mulan and the song reflection
someone decided to take advantage of
statues in a glass box and presented
this hilarious snapchat caption doesn't
it totally look like you singing the
reflection song in his head we love the
two-part snapchat caption to complete
the joke to his expression in the
reflection is pretty funny it's one of
our favorites and absolutely creative
we're telling you people on snapchat are
absolutely hilarious but mom it's
statues like these that make a museum
visit more entertaining because there
sweetly over-the-top have you ever
wondered why would someone decide to
portray that exact facial expression we
have no idea what happened here but it
does make it seem like the person is
super whiny and doesn't like the orders
his mom gave him doesn't it marble heads
are hilarious and we bet you can find
even more expressions like this one what
do you think this guy was really doing
to have this facial expression let us
know in the comments below
objecting to his mother seems very
fitting going downstairs one of the best
things ever is being hilarious snapchat
captions on iconic paintings like the
Last Supper
but this one also made us laugh out loud
if you're familiar with this painting
you know this is not really the case but
it really does look like he's trying to
pull the stairs trick we bet you can
find even funnier captions if you look
at other details on this painting what's
Mary Magdalene doing in the first place
look at Jesus's face he definitely
doesn't look impressed by what's
happening in the painting speaking of
none of their faces look particularly
amused with the going downstairs trick
sorry better luck next time new year we
told you people and historical paintings
just constantly look miserable and it
doesn't matter whether they're a man or
a woman you can put them in just about
any relatable situation and it'll be the
most hilarious thing ever like dis
snapchat caption that reminds you that
being single with New Year's
fast-approaching isn't always the best
thing ever just check out her facial
expression the woman's face really is
confirming that being single on New
Year's can be pretty miserable she's
really not having a good time with the
drink in front of her is she
Wi-Fi password now this one is just
absolutely hilarious and completely
relatable to every technology geek who's
always hunting for the Wi-Fi password
imagine historical people living in the
modern world we're pretty sure they'd go
through the same troubles as we do on a
regular basis whether it's Jesus or the
three kings some of their poses really
look like they're begging for a Wi-Fi
password how many times have you done
exactly the same and wanted to know the
Wi-Fi password historical people can't
relate but we bet they could if they
lived in the world of Wi-Fi reception
speaking of historians living in the
modern world apart from begging for the
Wi-Fi password they probably also look
for reception the poses these statues
make sometimes look completely
and I bet you can find quite a few
statues that would actually look like
they're trying to get some signal for
their phone especially if they're
located in a place that doesn't really
have any signal whoever created this
caption definitely knows what it feels
like to look for the Wi-Fi signal or
perhaps they're just trying to find the
best selfie angle since the lighting
behind the statue would be perfect
don't hate me we've already mentioned
some historian portraits are absolutely
fabulous and they really know how to
rock the royal style they look like
they're having tons of confidence staff
and a lot of attitude
they come with highlighted features and
some of the most amazing outfits we have
ever seen their poses are always over
the top and just like this gentleman it
seems like they do actually say don't
hate me because you ain't me
check out his hair and is over-the-top
fabulous outfit they are making quite
the statement it really feels like some
of these people think they have it all
and they're definitely pretty confident
Michael Jackson here's a hilarious one
that will make you have Michael Jackson
lyrics stuck in your head for the rest
of the day doesn't it look like this
person really is performing Michael
Jackson's Thriller the position of the
hands is just absolutely perfect and it
looks like the legs are also ready to go
now we really want to see the rest of
the choreography possibly joined by some
of the other portraits historians
performing the Thriller choreography
would be the best thing ever because
this is thriller thriller night and no
one's gonna save you from the Beast
about to strike
come on snapchat let's make it happen
not eating and last but not least some
people are able to turn the oddest
Museum situations into something totally
relatable and most importantly something
that can make everyone else laugh who
would have thought that looking at a
dinosaur could make someone think of the
time they haven't eaten in forever
it's exactly what it actually feels like
we bet that person hasn't actually eaten
in 3 hours and venturing the museum's
we know exactly what that feels like
have you ever felt like an extinct
dinosaur after not eating anything for
three hours this snapchat caption can
definitely relate and all we have to say
is thank you snapchat for making art fun
again that's it for 20 snapchat captions
that make art fun again for more videos
like this one check out 20 epic pet
costume ideas for Halloween see you next
time
[Music]